uh because we are a little bit late so i
will start
let's start with a quick agenda
we'll start with an introduction
uh then we'll talk very briefly what you
can get out of this workshop so you know
in advance
um then we'll prepare the environment i
will have one proposal for you but you
can also do it uh in a different way
then we'll talk about gns which stands
for graph neural networks
uh then we'll briefly talk about types
of gns and we'll only discuss a couple
of them
let's say a couple of classic types of
those
architectures
then we'll talk about spectral the
library the main library that we'll be
using today
and we will start
with seeing where this library fits in a
broader graph neural networks landscape
in python and then we'll talk about
basic uh components of spectral which
will be layers data sets and data
loaders
and then finally we'll do some practice
and we'll have a couple of practical
exercises
that hopefully will be valuable for you
and maybe
reusable for you in your own projects
and at the end
we'll have 10 minutes of questions q a
with you and with the online audience as
well
you can prepare your qr codes reader
because there will be some
interactive
things that
you can access using qr codes if you
don't have one there will be links as
well
on the presentation
okay
five sentences about myself my name is
alexander molock i'm a machine learning
engineer and researcher
at iron scales i'm also a machine
learning researcher at tensor cell this
is an independent
research initiative where we are usually
we are mainly focusing on our traffic
prediction
and traffic optimization
my main
expertise is natural language processing
i'm also interested in doing a lot of
stuff in probabilistic modeling and
causal inference which is closely
related to graph neural networks because
it also
leverages graph structures heavily
i'm an offer of sunday ai papers and
usually i'm saying that it's a weekly
that's it's a weekly linkedin based
micro blog
but last weeks were very very busy for
me so now it's not weekly anymore it was
not weekly it will be weekly again or
bi-weekly
i'm also interested in complex systems
psychology and neuroscience and this
part of my academic background and i
love traveling with my wife running i
enjoy vegan food and languages both
natural and and computer ones
okay what can you get from this workshop
there are a couple of things
first of all you will get some theory
behind gnns
but
as i say practical workshop will mainly
focus on practice we'll just do theory
in a in a bird's eye view let's say
second
no
you should get some practical knowledge
of of how to implement gns using
spectral and tensorflow keras we'll
mainly focus on keras interfaces because
they are simpler
but everything that we will do today can
be also done with more advanced lower
level tensorflow training loops
so if for whatever reason you need this
you will be able to to use this
to use those lower level interfaces as
well
and at the end we'll also
devote some time to preparing
a custom data set in spectral so this is
something and it's pretty important in
the in the whole graphene
neural networks workflow and which is
different than
anything we know from classical let's
call let's call it machine learning
so we'll do a
a short exercise on this and i will show
i will share some actual code that we
are using at tensor cell
with you so we can see how you can build
those data set objects
okay so let's jump to the environment
this is the repository for today
on the top you have a link here we have
a qr code you can use it as well and my
recommendation is that you use collab so
if you open collab and you type this uh
link
in the
on the on the welcome screen you should
be able to open the the notebook
you can also go to the repo you can
clone it and you can build the
environment locally there's an
environment file there but i do not
recommend this for the workshop because
there might be some complications
depending on your on your system and we
and we'll also have a little bits
of office speed up if we use gpu
so this is another thing
worth mentioning that when you're in
collab when you when you know when the
notebook is already open
you can go and change your
and change your acceleration type
okay so this is the direct link to the
notebook and now if you want to see how
to do it
okay so you have collab
then you
click this thing here github
and then you should put this link here
and when you say when you click enter
then you should have a notebook
pi data berlin
202204 by data berlin
wi-fi and then you click this link
and this should open the code for you in
color in the new window
okay so
let's jump further
so now we'll forget about the notebook
of course leave it open please because
we'll get back to it
uh but now let's talk about gns so what
are gns does anybody has an idea
it doesn't have to be a good definition
it's just about your ideas
okay we say graph neural networks how
are they different from regular neural
network
so alexander said that graph neural
networks operate
on the data that is structured as a
graph
and that they are trying to build a
representation of this graph
and this is a very good answer thank you
for this so let's
see
so first uh they operate on graphs
maybe maybe you also have this you have
the same name and the same presentation
in your computer i don't know
yeah
[Music]
another important thing is that they
need to permutation invariant
what does it mean it means that the
nodes in the graph if you take a graph
you can present this graph in many
different ways right so you can maybe
say like a b and c and you can rotate it
or you can in 3d you can rotate it this
way this way and it's still the same
graph
you can think about proteins in in human
body right they might have different
positions and we might look at them from
different perspectives but still we want
this pro this proteins to be the same
protein independently of how we look at
it
so you can think about nodes in a graph
as um elements of a set
okay so they are
they are not ordered the only thing that
matters are edges between those
those notes so connections
so we don't have an idea of where a
given node is about the location of this
node but we have an idea of a connection
of this node
okay and as alexander said we will try
to build a representation of a graph
that will abstract those connections
those local
connections of those nodes
and in a sense map them to some
space
where we will have
um
we will have a concept of
um
of position
and
this is very related to what we just
said they need to provide a meaningful
way to represent the data
now if you think about neural networks
i will give you something that i think
is very um closely related on the
conceptual level
if you think about
word embeddings for instance
so what where what we're embedding
algorithms are doing like where to vac
or maybe a transformer embedding layers
they're taking words
that are
categorical entities
and they are mapping them into some
space some continuous space
and they map them in in such a way that
words that is that are similar in the
meaning
are close to each other in the space
so if we compute something like maybe
cosine similarity cosine distance or
angular distance or maybe euclidean
distance between those points if if
those points two points representing
similar words
like maybe a maybe dog and puppy they
should be relatively um
relatively not far away from each other
while words that have
meaning that is very different like
maybe
a
rocket scientist should be somewhere
further apart or maybe a i don't know a
truck
so here we are doing something similar
but we are not using words all the words
or sentences could be seen as a graph
which is like a chain graph
[Music]
but we are trying to map notes that are
similar to points that are not far away
from each other and nodes that are
dissimilar to make them further apart
from each other
and when we are building this data
representation
we can use
three different types of information so
it's information about the node itself
so those nodes
at minimum they need to have something
that identifies them uniquely
maybe a one whole encoded vector with
one in y position and zero
everywhere everywhere else
or they might have some features so they
might at minimum have one have one
feature
[Music]
and we want to use this information
about note itself we want to use
information about nodes neighbors in
terms of
their maybe identifiers maybe of their
feature vectors
and we want to use the information about
information about the local
structure and local structure is defined
by the neighborhood
so how a node is connected to to other
other
nodes or with how many nodes it is
connected
this is a
this is a picture from from this paper
which is called semi-supervised
classification with graph convolutional
networks by thomas kipp and max welling
and this is a paper from 2017 so it's a
couple years
a couple years ago already but this is
one of a very very
classical
graph neural networks
architectures that they proposed and
what they are doing here basically is
that they are taking some graphs so
those black things
are edges
between the nodes those circles are
edges obviously
and now we are taking all the
information that we have in these nodes
and
we put them through a couple a couple of
hidden layers one or maybe a couple of
hidden layers and we build some other
representations now
what we can do with those
representations we can for instance use
them to classify the nodes but we can
also use them to classify the classify
the graph the whole graph we can also
use them for any regression task
and any any other task that you can
think of
uh with classical machine learning so
you can think about graph neural
networks
as a type of a special
as a type of a special encoder
right so
we need some special encoder to deal
with graph
structure
but then when we are in this
representation layer
we can use this representation layer in
any
way that we could use any other
representation obtained in any other
using any other
encoder deep encoder
and i want to show you uh i want to
share with you one example which comes
also from the same paper from captain
welling
um this is a data set this is that
that's that's not that is but that is
called a karate club network it's a very
simple as you can see very simple
relatively small
um graph neural graph data set
and this is how you how you embed it
when you embed it so all of each of
these notes they have some features
and then you can embed them
in in this two-dimensional
space and this is what you get when you
just
embed them just like this
um oh sorry i think they even don't have
features so this is just a random
random weighting
and then
when we use a graph neural networks in
particular in this case gcn a graph
convolutional network you can see that
after 25 iterations those points are
starting to group together
given their class right so the caller is
uh they are marked their classes are
marked by the call by their callers
after 50 it goes
it's it's even more ordered than 75 100
and finally 300 and you can see that
all the blue notes are here green are
here
and there's purple are here
now
those edges that are here
are not anymore in those representations
they are in the picture just to show you
how those notes were connected in the
original graph we have a question we
have two questions okay but you were
first where do the colors come from in
the first place
the colors come from the classes so in
this data set you have like four classes
not three but four sorry i missed one
and these notes are colored uh according
to the classes
so each note was
does it answer your question yes okay
great and you have a question
sorry what's your name thomas thomas
very nice to meet you
jacob
um
no so i don't want to i don't want to
confuse you now so let's forget about
this random weights okay
they are classified because of of
because of something right
in the in the original data set now we
apply a graph neural network to them
and based on the connections of those
nodes
and maybe some features i'm sorry i
don't remember if this data set has uh
node features or not maybe it has
then we build a representation for each
node
and now
how we do it we'll show we'll show this
in a second but basically we are trying
to leverage these three types of
information that we mentioned on one of
the previous slides so information about
node itself if it has a feature vector
it's
this information is preserved then
information about its neighbors
and then the information about the local
structure okay so how this this
particular node and this particular node
will be each of those nodes
at some point does this answer your
question
yes
okay great thank you
okay so let's talk about graph
representation we'll talk about nodes
edges
and features so we actually already
talked about this
nodes are just nodes edges are
connections between connections between
those nodes and features are
vectors
or scalars can be if they only have one
feature
that are
combined or connected to
a given node
now
from computational point of view how do
we represent this so we have something
that is called adjacency matrix
adjacency matrix is basically a matrix
that has a shape of number of nodes
and number of nodes
and it has zeros everywhere where there
are no connections and ones where there
are connections
so for instance if you imagine a
that we have a graph that has three
features
this matrix will have three rows and
three columns
and if you have ones on the diagonal and
zeros every everywhere else
this graph will be a little bit strange
because it will only have self edges so
self loops so called so edges from
itself from the nodes to itself
but if you have for instance like
0 1 0 and then all the zeros this means
that
node number one is connected to node
number two
but everything else is disconnected does
it make sense
okay we have a question what's your name
this is a place where the
symmetry shows up
in a sense because
you could actually
you could actually mix those
those um those nodes right so we can
change their positions and the matrix
will be different
but but still uh what the neural network
will be looking at
are connections so it doesn't matter if
node one is node 1 i can also move it to
be node 2 now
the network should land the same
the same representation basically
we have another question
so it's a very good question
we can have directed or undirected
graphs
and if it's undirected we will have to
have one
like one
here
and then
the same mirror image in the
in the in the column space and in the
raw space right
does it answer a question yes
thank you
okay and the second thing is a feature
matrix
so we will usually have some some
features
and those features
um this feature matrix will have a shape
of number of nodes
versus dimensionality of features so if
we have like five features we have three
nodes and five features it will be three
over five
okay
does it make sense
any questions
we have one question
i'm not sure if it will appear later on
do we have uh features on the edges
themselves
so the what's your name
costa okay so costa asks a very good
question
can we also have features on the edges
and the short answer is yes
and we have
graph neural network architectures that
might also work with edge features
but
for just for today we won't use them
okay so today we will only using node
features because it's already a lot of
stuff going on yes we have another
question
uh i'm not sure if i understood the
question so you said what's your name
so we usually have like an edge feature
matrix as well
and and by the way how those networks
are constructed we take those take those
features into account like edge features
into account
the dimension of
the feature
matrix artificial nodes to
uh no so we usually have a separate
matrix for this
for for edge features
we might have a separate
matrix for edge features
okay sorry if if you want to we can
discuss this after but i don't want to
devote too much time uh to this um now
because we won't make use of this
okay so how does it work
so let's take this graph
and
for now we'll just focus on
on this note node a
so to build a representation of node a
we'll take some function of
of nodes b and c y b and c because these
are the only nodes that are connected
here okay and for now let's forget if
it's directed or undirected
just for the case of simplicity and i
call this a prime because this will be
like
another layer so this is let's say this
is our input layer
and then we are constructing the
representation for the first layer
and we can stack those layers on and on
um
now
this looks simple
in fact it's a little bit more
complicated not much
so usually what we do
we take some function of b and c
and this function could be
could be split into
two functions again
usually we'll take something like a
multi-layer perception of
b and of c
and then apply some aggregation function
here
so maybe it can be a sum summing maybe
it can be average maybe it can be max
and then when we aggregate those
features
we pass them through some activation
function usually a nonlinear function to
make it more expressive
and we apply this
to each node
in the network
okay
and here it assumes that this is
directional in this direction right
because otherwise b should also be a
function of a
and then we do it and for each layer
we repeat this set of operations
so now one important thing is
that you can notice that if we have just
one layer
a
will be only looking at b and c
so so called one hop neighborhood
if you would like a
to be able to see nodes that are further
apart
in two hop or n-hop or k-hop
neighborhood we need n or k layers
okay
so depending on your problem
you might want a very deep network or
maybe a very shallow network
yes of course so we say a prime here
because this is a representation of node
a
in the next layer comparing to this so
this is like an input layer
and then we have the first hidden layer
and we call it a prime
does this make sense
okay
thank you
okay so now let's talk about types of
gnns and we'll talk a little bit more
about how they work
so there are many
graph neural networks architectures i
will tell you about three of them today
a classic ones
these are called gcn that stands for
graph convolutional network
and this is in a sense a generalization
of what we
call a convolutional layer in
computer vision or sequential modeling
then we have graph sage which is like a
more in a sense more versatile
architecture that can have
different aggregation functions
and finally the third one that we are
talking about today
is called gat
graph attention network
so as you can um as you can imagine this
one leverages the attention mechanism
when learning those representations
and we'll focus on the first one and the
third one today so we will talk briefly
about gcn
and g8t in terms of theory how they work
and then we will implement both of them
and we have many many more so
even if you go to the website from spec
of spectral
which is the library that we'll be using
today they have implementations of many
many layers
starting from simple layers like gin
to to pretty advanced stuff
okay so how does gcn work
we'll do some introduce a little bit of
mathematics now but not too much
so now i want what i want to do i want
to make take this notation that we had
like a b and so on and make it a little
bit more abstract
and we'll say that h
is a representation of like any node in
the network
node v in this case
and this l here in the bracket means
layer stands for layer
so representation of node of node v
in layer l
is
representation of layer of
of each of its neighbors
so we take all the neighbors of u of v
sorry
neighbors of v
we call each of those neighbors u
so in this case for for the node eight
would be b and c as we make is directed
in this case actually it doesn't matter
and then what we do
we divide this representation
by the number of
uh of neighbor neighbors so this is
basically what we're doing here we're
averaging we're averaging
those
we're averaging representation of all
the neighbors of our node
and then we multiply this by some weight
matrix
and this weight matrix
has two important properties first it's
learnable
so we learn this matrix during the
training and second it's shared
okay
when we have this when we take this
average because we have summation and
the division
we send it to some non-linearity that's
all that's graph convolutional network
do you think there are any problems with
this approach
so so the common is that we might have
circular references so we might learn
the representation of of the node itself
in a sense in a circular way is that
correct i understand correct yes
that's true
it can happen but it's not necessarily a
bad thing
uh one thing that is
a problem here is the averaging
because you can think of it
like
because of averaging
there will be situations
where we won't be able to differentiate
between two different neighborhoods
so maybe you think let's let's let's
forget about d and e or maybe different
um
let's say
uh it's not a good example well by
averaging by averaging we basically
might build the same representation for
two different neighborhoods
assuming that they have certain um
values in their features right
so
average of
two elements of eight is eight and
average of four elements of four is four
right and they would be represented
identically here and this might be a
problem doesn't have to be a problem
depending on your on your problem we had
a question and we had another one
is
okay so the question is what is the
initial representations of those um
of those
of this
and the second is about the
if this matrix can change the dimension
okay
yes so
uh so this doesn't have to be squared so
you we can compress those
representations or we can expand them
anything you want
and this
in the first layer this is the input the
input feature vector of a given node
so i said that it can be scalar
technically if you have just one feature
but
but even more technically we even
represent a scalar as a vector in
computations because we want to have
dimensions in in place
okay
so this
yes
learning right
yes so learning great it's so everything
like things like learning grade and
batch size and everything you can think
of also applies here so now we are only
looking at like let's say functions that
are mapping uh that are mapping
uh
nodes to other nodes so we are just
focusing on this very very small part
and then of course when you when you
when you do this you apply this one time
in one layer maybe another time in
another layer and then finally you got
to i don't know classification or
regression layer and there's some error
and we want to back propagate we have
learning rate of course and we have
yes yes so all the methodology from
neural networks applies here this is
only this part that is as we said in the
beginning it's different than what we
have in classical machine learning
because we have this encoding and we
have this very special
structure in the data
thank you
it's a very good question
okay g80 very quickly
we changed something here what have we
changed
no averaging exactly what do we have
instead
huh
yes but alpha we didn't have alpha there
look
yes
yes we don't know what alpha that's a
very good that's a very good remark
but what is it what can it be
edge weights
okay uh we could think of it this way uh
yes
specific weighting factor depending on
connection that's a very nice answer
maybe to drop out some connections very
good intuition
number of connections
okay what do we have here in the index
what are v and u what are those
nodes exactly
neighbors somebody said good yes you are
first i think it depends on what you
will optimize later in the equation so i
mean the w will be optimized during your
run and for the alpha it's not clear
it might come in
from the structure of the network yes so
so we have a remark that
we know that w is being optimized in
alpha we don't know
of course we don't know so far very good
attention yes
yes and all the answers were very good
so
in short its attention this is attention
a vector of attention weights and we had
another from alexander um
more
bro a broader an extended answer that
this is a coefficient that tells us how
important is node u for node v
in
for so node
u in the previous layer for node v in
the next layer
and this is attention mechanism how it's
implemented well in the paper it was
implemented in one way you can think of
different attention mechanisms and you
can apply apply them here but basically
this is what we've said so
we instead of just averaging we are
taking a weighted average
but
and this answer answers to your question
we also learn
those weightings so
this is another
is another parameter in the network that
we are learning during the training
okay
yes
the question is if this is constrained
if they have to sum up to one
yes in a sense because they are
normalized so there's a soft max
operation over those weights
okay so we had gcn that averages
neighbor neighboring representations and
we have g80 that learns attention over
those representations
so now we will go to something more down
to the earth and we'll talk about
spectral the library that we'll be using
today and i need to speed up because we
are over time but hopefully this
uh everything we talked about will help
us
be faster in the next part
okay so gn and landscape like landscape
in python
is pretty rich already
and we have i will i will just talk
about three
types of
libraries
maybe there are more i don't know i will
share with you what i know
so first we have back in diagnostic
frameworks like dgl
deep graph library
so you can use this with tensorflow you
can use this with pytorch you can use
this with mxnet
next we have python based frameworks
like python geometric
and this is a very very much record
ecosystem
that has also many sub-libraries like
python geometric temporal
and so on and so on you have
the research community around python
geometric is very rich
so many papers are implemented and so on
and finally we have tensorflow based
frameworks
and we have tensorflow gnn
that we are not using today and we have
a very good reason for this because this
is like a very very very
early stage library
and i think it's still in alpha and
there are many problems with it and
there's finally spectral
that we will be using today so why
spectral
i told you a lot of good stuff about
python geometric and
i think that's all true
but if you use tensorflow or you prefer
tensorflow or your production system is
in tensorflow
you will probably uh pick spectral dgl
might be your choice as well
but as if as with keras before being
integrated into tensorflow you were not
able to you are not able to go
super deep sometimes so if you want to
do
something more advanced something more
low level spectral probably will be your
way to go because it integrates smoothly
with
with both keras and tensorflow and you
can go as deep as you want with custom
training loops and actually virtually
anything
okay so let's think
about
main components of spectral
so i will talk about three of them
though you might argue that there are
more
and first the most important one is
layers so we have convolutional layers
and convolutional layers
is a broad term
that
embraces everything we talked about so
gcns
gats
graph sage and many many other layers
so the stem convolution is used very
broadly here
it captures all of the
all of the graph layers that they have
and
excluding pooling
layers that are
just taking these
representations
and pulling them together into something
that can be then passed to like a
classical dance or classical convolution
or whatever other type of layer you want
then we have base layers
which is just the base for building your
own classes and we have models so you
have
those layers
implemented with other layers combined
with other layers
pretty often as it was done in original
paper so in the gcn paper by kip van
welling or gat paper
uh that introduced this g80 network uh
by velikovic and and
colleagues next we have data loaders and
this is very important because
we
different approach to data than
than with classical neural networks or
classical machine learning because we
have those feature matrices because we
have those adjacency matrices and in
some cases we also have
other matrices that
have indices
which nodes belong to which graph
because we might have a huge
data set
that contains many graphs
um
which is currently which is called as a
disjoint mode we will talk about this a
little bit
uh more later and finally you have data
sets so if you want to
maybe you just want to experiment with
something or maybe you don't want to
start with your very large data set you
want to do a quick poc you can use some
of those data sets and they have
everything all the classics are
available like coda which is a citation
data set
tu data sets which is a bunch of uh
well very broad very broad scope of of
graph data sets
okay so now it's practice time we can go
back to the notebook
here's the old link still
great
oh is this like this maybe
yes
so if you are in collab one important
thing is that you need to uncomment this
stuff and click shift enter
okay i think it will be installing for
for for a while so i'll tell you what we
have in inputs here so we import os
which will be only important for our
data sets at the end then numpy for some
manipulations we input spectral as
spk trl
tensorflow stf
tf keras is keras and then from spectral
data set we will take citation data set
which is cora the data set that we
mentioned before and tu data set which
is actually a bunch of data sets
then we also import two data loaders so
we said that this is an important
piece of code that is very very helpful
because of
[Music]
graph structure and as you can see we
have two different
data loaders single data loader and
disjoint data loader so single data
loader
will
import something that is like just one
one single graph
and this join data loader will import
something that is
a set of graphs but that is encoded as
one huge
matrix
which is basically
a set of
matrices put on a diagonal of a huge
matrix okay
and each sub-matrix on this diagonal
will be will be a diff will be different
a different matrix sometimes it's easier
to encode a graph like this
and more efficient
to process
and then we when then we actually don't
import this
and we import data set and graph and
both things are something that we will
use for
uh four data sets do we have anyone who
is still installing the libraries
no okay so we have all the libraries
installed okay so you can so you can
import the libraries but before please
go to
in call up to your
i don't remember how it's called to
check if you have gpu um turned on
huh
it will be faster yes
so please make sure in collab that you
have gpu
if there's anyone who doesn't know how
to do it just let me know
okay one two people three okay
okay so we have i will show you then
because it will be faster
because we have more than two people
collab
and open this
so you go to run time
and then you go change runtime type
and then hardware accelerator and you
pick gpu
and then you click save
okay
do we all have it
yes
okay
yes sorry
i'm sorry yes unfortunately
okay so let's wait uh one minute to
turn on gpus and reinstall if this is
necessary
yes of course you can make a question
okay so it's a very good question thank
you uh so the question is what is the
most practical problem that you can
solve with graph neural networks so from
business point of view pretty often it's
about
social networks
from well business point of view and
scientific point of view
it's about for instance proteins
modeling drug interactions
predicting toxicity of a given substance
um
it's also about
in neuroscience it's about connectivity
in the brain so trying to understand
something maybe build a generative model
maybe build a predictive model
is there ways to deal with
time-dependent networks
for example very good questions so the
question is
is there a way to deal with
time-dependent networks like transport
networks for example yes and there are
special packages for this like python
geometric temporal
where you can
relatively easy encode graphs that are
changing in time and make predictions in
time as well
one more question
very good question what's your name
nicholas nicolas asked if there is
something like skip connections in this
architectures there can be so you can
think about this as we said in the
beginning you can think about it as a
type of a special encoder and now what
you do inside this encoder and also in
the whole architecture
it's
sky is the limit so there are
architectures using skip connections
and this is something that tends to work
very well in certain
contexts
but today we won't do we won't do this
actually we'll have an exercise so you
can try a skip connection as well
but you can definitely do this and you
can do this within the
graph uh block and you can also do this
like when you are in in the dance block
like so you have already encoded
representation and so on
okay uh do we have anyone still waiting
for the installation
nope great
okay so if you click this
second cell or the third cell you should
see something like this physical gpus
and spectral and tensorflow versions do
we all have it
okay assuming that we'll have it thank
you
okay let's get the data so we'll state
start with with the core with core data
set you can use this link if you want to
read more about it
we're using this citation class which we
imported before from spectral data sets
and we say that this is cora
and we are normalizing our x features so
let's do some exploratory data analysis
we said that
from technical point of view if you want
to encode all of this we have something
we call adjacency matrix and then we
said we have something that we call a
feature matrix so let's see what is the
dimensionality of our adjacency matrix
you can see that this is two thousand
seven hundred something over two
thousand seven hundred something why is
it a square
matrix exactly this is nodes versus
nodes because we are looking at
connections between nodes so on the
diagonal what would we have
yes but if we have ones on the diagonal
what does it mean self loops exactly
very good and you and
themselves so
self citing yeah
you should not have them right
okay
so we have in those data sets we have
this adjacency matrix we said feature
matrix we have it we also have something
called y which is labels okay
and in this particular data set because
this is just one graph one huge graph
not that huge one well reasonably
large graph we also have labels so for
each
for each note
we have a label
how many labels do we have
seven labels exactly
good so now it's time for you for your
first exercise display the label
of note 77 what is the label for this
node
okay
so although this is just one graph
we are saying data set 0 we are indexing
this there's just one index but this is
because we want to be
generalizable
so this is your data set if you want to
access labels it's dot y the attribute y
of your data set
and then we need
label number 75 who has the answer
77 sorry you're right
okay so what does it mean
seventh category so this is one these
labels this is very important thing
these labels are one hot encoded right
which means that we will have one
on the index
that marks the number of our class
so we should do something like this
and this is the last
thing so it's like because we are in
python so with 0
zero one two three four five six
seven something wrong no good it's six
sorry sorry
because the labels are coming from zero
yeah
yes so this is zero one two three four
five six
okay
that's a good point yeah so i'm i'm i'm
telling you that python is zero index
but then i'm doing this
exactly so this is the other label thank
you thank you
you're right you're absolutely right
okay so let's understand features
features are encoded as this under this
attribute uh you can find them under
this attribute x
what is the dimensionality of the
features
what is the dimensionality of the
features in coral data set you have the
answer on the
exactly 1433 this means that we have
1433 features for each node
those features are
one hot encoded words from the articles
okay so we have
actually they picked 1043
1433
words that they thought maybe are
are
they have some predictive power and they
said this word is in this ethical this
word is this word is the other one is
not
that's all
so now let's see what is the
distribution of this you can see that
this is extremely sparse sparse so what
we see on this histogram
is we are counting how many
how many words per article do we have
you can see that the like
the median well the mode is like 20.
i don't know if it's medium so it's like
this the larger mode is 20
uh which means that we have only 20 ones
out of
1433 this is very very sparse extremely
sparse
okay
so
now
there is something that we we are using
for this particular data set it's just
like uh it's not
important in general it's
uh just an item in this data set we have
those masks tr states stands for
training
va stands for validation and te stands
for test and this is basically
a train validation test split so we will
use this to mask certain nodes in our
data set
and then use
those nodes for validation and for test
but they will be invisible during the
training okay now it's time for your
exercise number two
we need to check how many training
examples how many
validation examples and how many test
examples we have so you should replace
those
ellipses ellipses here
with something like this to get the
answer
okay do we have an answer
okay go on you're after you you're the
first
exactly so i'll do it as well here on
the screen
so we can see it
train
and test
so this means that our training set is
very very small
our validation set is larger which is
well in a sense it's good and our test
set is even larger so this means that if
this network works well
we would expect that it would it should
have pretty good generalization right at
least in this realm
of something similar
okay so
now we're going back to loaders
so loaders will take this data set so it
they will take those x's a's and y's and
i's and e's if it's there
and they will structure them
in a way
that will be compatible with the library
interface
and it will it will make it possible for
us to use
all those training structures that we
know from keras and tensorflow
so high-level apis making just uh the
whole work much much easier
so first we'll use the functional api
who have used keras functional api
before
okay
okay
who has used the kera subclassic modal
subclassing api before
okay one person two people okay okay so
so the idea about functional api is that
you start with some inputs
then you build some layers
and you pass these inputs to these
layers but not to the layer constructor
you just call those layers on
those inputs or whatever then you build
some
maybe another layer
and then
you also call this layer on
this thing here we have two things be
because this is a uh attention this is a
graph layer so we need
uh our data representation that comes
from the dropout layer
but we also need and this is
critical we need
this in a which stands for
our
adjacency matrix okay we need to pass
this adjacency matrix so this layer
knows where are the connections between
the nodes
then we continue with this i will show
you a couple of more examples to
familiarize you with this then we take
another layer this layer is not a graph
specific right it's it's just a regular
dropout layer so we only pass
the data representation okay we are not
passing adjacency matrix
then we have another layer which is a
gat
which is a graph layer which means that
we need to pass what
adjacency matrix exactly so we pass our
data representation that comes from the
dropout layer the second dropout layer
but also we add the adjacency matrix
and finally we encapsulate all of this
in a keras model
so we take the model class from keras
this is keras from tensorflow but it
doesn't matter
and then we specify inputs and we have
two inputs because we have a feature
matrix which is called in x and
adjacency matrix which is called which
is called n a
and then we specify outputs we have just
one output this is our final g80 layer
and an important thing is that look the
activation function of this layer is
softmax which means that we will use it
for
classification exactly
so
we don't use any other we if if that
would be like a deep layer we could use
cellu or relu or
hyperbolic tangent or anything like this
here we are using softmax we could also
use nothing
and and build a regression problem but
for this we
would typically use also a dense layer
after this
okay let's try to run it
okay we have one question there
no we don't have a question okay
okay let's set up some parameters so you
were asking before about learning rate
now it's time to set up the learning
rate so you can see that in this
1.4.2
we are setting the learning rate number
of epochs we say 10 000 but we just say
10 000 to make it like okay if it needs
to it will run
it will finish much
much earlier we also said patience to 30
why can we use something why do we
why
why might we need something like
patience what would that mean
yes
the parameters are definitely not
exactly so so for instance we we don't
want to we don't want to waste resources
if the model is not learning anymore we
will use something that is called early
stopping
and patience is 30 which means 30 epochs
so if for 30 epochs there is no progress
we'll just stop the training and as you
can we will see in a second we'll also
get back to the weights the best weights
that we found on the way another
question
again again
batching
we are using batching
not in this um
not in this context we we will talk
about batching in this
in the second exercise okay i don't want
to go into this but that's a very good
question
so for now
uh let's compile the model we are
compiling the model
and we are training the model and as a
as and as you can see we are using this
led stopping callback here
we are also reducing learning rate on
plateau i don't want to get into this
this is like more like deep learning
stuff
and let's run this training it should be
relatively fast
okay yours can you can see that we are
starting with validation accuracy of 0.3
so this is not very good
also accuracy might not be the best
metric here
but for now we are going with this
you can see that now around epoch number
one five five we are at 96 already so
this is good
yes
so on this data set what do the seven
labels mean in real life
so the seven labels in this data set
they mean
the area that the article is coming from
so maybe it's computer science or
neuroscience or psychology or biology or
something like this
from all of them like so so the the
these words are independent like they
are they are this
the set of words is the same for each
area for all the areas sorry
the set of uh the set of so the set of
words
that consist our features
is independent of the labels
okay so maybe we have a word computer
and it will appear in i don't know maybe
we have a word neural network and it
will appear in mostly in artificial
intelligence papers
and maybe just sometimes it will appear
in psychological papers but very rarely
right
but we don't have uh
so so these words they are coming from
all of the areas
and i don't i don't remember how they
picked them but it's not the same
the same words what do you mean by this
so the
words of this article
right so this would be different in
different streams different streams yes
yes yes so so so yeah so you have a
biological article so in this biological
article you will have words like cell or
life or something
[Music]
this particular network has like a
slightly different purpose so we want to
classify the notes so
you're sending me an article
nodes
so each node is an article one node is
one article
based on the keywords but also on the
connections
right because we are taking citations
into account so we could we could show
that if we take just the keywords and we
ignore connections and we train a
regular neural network on this
then our results will be much much worse
okay
and that's the idea of this um
of this encoder okay so my model has
trained i don't know how about your
models let's see
how the loss goes it goes okay we could
actually stop probably a little bit
earlier and let's evaluate the model
it's 0.998 so this is a very good result
let's go back to
the size of those
training and test sets
and so based on 140 articles and the
information about these citations were
able to predict almost almost all of the
thousand articles correctly
again again
[Music]
yes
is is less yes i understand uh i don't
know
you can go to the cora website and and
check this maybe they had some idea for
this
yes
uh arbitrarily like a graph structure
you mean
you can you can so so when we were
talking about like those dcns and gats
and we were talking about those uh
weight matrices we said that they have
two important properties
so one important property was that they
are
learnable so we are learning them into
training and the second one and i think
this should answer your question is that
they are shared
which means that we could potentially
push a sub graph or another graph
and it should be able to generate
predictions based on this training and
we'll see an example of this
in the second exercise
so you can so you can learn those
weights on one graph and then
generalize them or use them on another
graph and they should work as well
does it answer a question
yes
okay
if i've understood correctly um the
structure of the network takes into
account the immediate neighborhoods of
each node that's at least what i read
from the formula you gave earlier so is
it possible to extend this so that you
extend like to like not only one node
neighborhoods but also neighborhoods yes
so the question is
that from the formula that we've seen um
it seems that those networks are taking
into account the image the immediate or
one hope neighborhood into a into
account right uh that's true and
the question is if we can extend it we
can extend it by adding more layers so
adding each layer is going one hop
further of course this is not entirely
true because we can have those self
loops
not direct self loops and so on and then
it might be different but yeah and then
the additional question is
but then you will get in trouble with
train test splits right because you get
um if you take more neighborhoods into
account you have to also take into
account this for your transaction we are
masking we are masking the we're masking
those yes training if you if for example
in a node in your uh two hub two hop
neighborhood is in the test set
but
your original note is in the training
set
yeah but we are we are splitting before
we start training
so this representation is being
propagated during the training right so
if it's cut off before the training then
you're altering your data at the end
you're altering your data yes okay
that's that's the difference
yes but this is how it is so so of
course and there's also there are many
problems of course
with with this type of networks if you
want to go very deep
so you might have things like over
squashing
or over smoothing which means that we
might go if if you think about it if we
do this like
um if number of layers goes to infinity
the representation of nodes
goes uniform
right because i'm taking all the
information from my neighborhood and
again and again and again and again and
each node is becoming essentially the
same
when number of
layers goes to infinity so there are
limitations to this framework for sure
so this is a very good intuition
okay
so
um
i have a
i have a another exercise for you
but we are a little bit out of time
so my proposal is that we go with
another structure and you can do the
exercise at home
or
we can do the exercise now but then we
might not be able to do the second uh
the second part so who votes who votes
for going for the second part
who does want to do the exercise instead
okay so that's clear so we're going with
the second part
okay so
for cora we're trying to classify
articles and articles were represented
as nodes in our graph now we'll try to
do something else so now we'll try to
classify graphs okay so we'll take we'll
try to take a bunch of graphs
and their labels
and
we'll try to land weights that we could
take and apply to another set of graphs
to meaningfully predict the labels
and this is so we were talking about
those data loaders and so on and i i
told you that we can encode sometimes
many data sets in one matrix and this is
precisely these things that we're
talking about
so we have a large matrix
that contains that has like many
adjacency matrices
around on the diagonal
and then we have another matrix that
contains
features for this
so we can do this for
storage reasons for computational
reasons and so on and so on and this is
what we will have here so now we are
reading a data set
and this data set is called proteins so
now
each single graph in this data set
will represent one protein one protein
okay
so now the question for you is
how many nodes are in the eighth eighth
graph of proteins data set and how many
nodes are in the 172nd
so this is how you do it we'll go
further
you can answer the second question
yourself
and here we do something else when it
comes to trained test split we are just
taking like a random split
but then essentially we are doing
something very similar but instead of
using single loader we are using this
joint loader and this joint loader is
something that will work with a graph
like this
with a graph encoded like this so many
graphs in one in one
matrix
and now we are we will use so in the
previous example we used graph attention
network now we will use a gcn
so the first architecture that we
mentioned today
now one difference between those two
situations is that now we have
there are a couple of differences but
we don't we know we do not only have x
and a so features and adjacency matrix
we also have this i and this i
is a set of indices
that picks
uh particular graphs from this huge
matrix that contains all of the graphs
okay so it just takes like okay maybe
one graph one and two and three
okay
and now we are also using something that
is called model subclassic api
and we inherit from keras models model
we have some in it where we define our
network structure and what we have here
is
uh we have this gcn layer
then we have maybe more gcn layers if we
want we have some
global average pooling
then we have a dense layer dropout and
dense again
that's all
and then an important function or
important method in in this model
subclassing api is this call function
or call method
that calls the whole
the whole thing
so i will run this
again some setup learning create only 10
epochs this time
we
instantiate the model
run the optimizer
and train
the dimension of the input layer is the
dimension of uh
the dimension of uh features
no because nodes are so
so in a sense what is going on within
this uh within this gcn layer that we've
seen
earlier
is
actually inside this gcn layer you have
a set of small neural networks between
nodes
yes
but if you think about so this is a
tricky question in a sense right
so so
it takes connections
and it has the set of neural networks
that are building those representations
then applying this non-linearity that we
talked about before
but then
the dimension
of this
is channels so so it will take
and the input it will take for each node
it will take a feature vector
dimension maybe it's like i know 2 000
and it will squash it to number of
channels maybe 36 and in another layer
maybe we want to expand
64. and then maybe expand again 1128.
then we want to compress 16 and so on so
we can think of it like in a sense did
they so it's like if you think about if
you abstract the graph structure it just
goes like a regular i don't know
convolutional network or dance network
but
behind the scenes
it also applies those little neural
networks that compute the representation
for each of the nodes
but the global feature dimension for
each node is defined by channels here
makes sense
so inside so inside it's all it's all um
um
you can make it very efficient on matrix
multiplication so you so you just
multiply adjacency matrix by the feature
matrix by the reverse of
one of those matrices inverse of one of
those matrices and and you will get all
those computations so it all happens
simultaneously in a sense
inside right but from like let's say
abstract point of view the
dimensionality is just driven by those
channels and this dimensionality will be
identical in each layer will be
identical for each node
does it answer your question
yes
so with this let's let's leave it for q
a okay
uh that's a very good question but uh
let's leave it for q a
um because i want to complete this okay
so as you can see
we we actually started with a better
result than we got at the end
right and we don't have early stopping
here which means that we just finished
with those weights which are still
with the weights giving us this result
which is still well reasonable so
there's an exercise for you you can add
more layers so we we talked about
generate
about listening to this one hub versus
k-hop neighborhoods so you can add more
layers for yourself
and experiment with this
and finally i wanted to talk to tell you
about building your own data sets
but actually
i think let's leave this five minutes
for questions
you can read this here
and also check the spectral website
and you have this class that is like
actually and the actual code that we
used at tensorcell for one of the
experiments for our
traffic optimization experiments
and you can look at this code try to
understand what is going on here
one thing that is important in those
data sets is that they should inherit
from the data set class
and they need to have this read method
where read just reads the graph from a
given location and then you can do
anything you want
in this read
read class and another thing is very
important you should output a graph
so graph is imported from spectral and
it should have x a and y and maybe also
e if you have edge features
and this if you structure a code like
this it will be ready to be passed to
any tensorflow or keras training
api that you that you would like to use
okay
great so
i go back to the presentation now
and you see my screen like this it's
just not good
okay
okay
so here is the survey
you can click this and answer a couple
of questions that should not take you
more than one minute i'll be very
grateful for this because your feedback
will make my future presentations better
so you can help other people to oh wow
sorry about this what is going on with
this
now it should be stable
and i'm ready to take your questions and
questions from people online because i
suppose we also might get some something
from there
yeah so before jumping into questions
let's thank alexander for the very nice
toil
so thank you so much there are not so
many questions on the live chat there
was one about
uh
if the
node v is contained in the subset of
nodes in your formula
if you know
u in the number of
near neighbors of v
is v in that set as well uh-huh so this
will be a self-loop so-called so
actually uh
actually in fact gcn for instance is
if i remember correctly the original
implementation takes uh denote itself
into account so it takes its own
representation as well
but sometimes it's worth to experiment
with this and even if your architecture
takes the self-representation into
account
you might want to add self-loops if you
don't have them in your data set you
might want to add self-loops in your
adjacency matrix and it might affect
your
results positively this is my experience
at least in with some architectures let
me just finish with these ones and then
we can jump into the question from the
audience so another question is a
what's a let's say how do you compare
like a
gnns as compared to for getting the
graph structure and just using nnns or
lstms or things like this for getting
the graph structure yeah so like like
catastrophic forgetting like in in
transformers or like i think it's just
simply like like what let's say what do
you think if you have a network like a
graph neural network and instead of
using gnns you just use a classical
neural network okay yeah so so multiple
experiments showed that if there is a
graph structure and this graph structure
is meaningful to the problem
then graph neural networks will give you
better results
so i encourage you to in the repository
you have also the a folder with papers i
encourage you to go to those papers
these are papers describing gcn and jt
and you can see also comparisons between
graph neural networks and regular neural
networks applied to those problems all
right those were the two questions we
have so we have questions from the
audience okay so let's let's start with
with the at the end sorry don't worry
thanks um so i have two questions um
first is how does it scale if we start
to speak about like the millions of
nodes and my second question would be
how do you deal with bipartite graph i'm
thinking let's say you have a series of
customers and a series of vendors
yes uh so very good question thank you
um
scaling scaling is a real challenge so
with millions you're probably
you're probably still good
uh but you know there are things like
pinterest or something where they have
like millions thousands of millions
um
so
notes thousands of millions uh notes so
what people are trying to do in those
circumstances is trying to they're
trying to take uh sap graphs
on sub graphs or sample
and
there are many sample techniques
that you that are trying to make sure
that you're not losing too much
information
and the second question the part of the
question
bipartite graphs
with bipartite graphs i don't have
experience with this
but you can do it so the so there are
methods uh designed specifically for
heterogeneous graphs
where you can have bipartite or
tripartite
graphs
and you can also have uh multiple types
of edge features so so there are methods
for this they are actually let's say
like uh
trying to
to
take those methods like gcn and just
apply them to more general settings
general settings
if you go to spectral documentation you
will find you will find methods like
this or python geometric you will find
and there are links to the papers
here
first things the the presentation was
really awesome
thank you i wanted to ask about uh like
the data set for um a graph the
classification of the whole graph
like is it common that you have just
just feet you have a data set of just
many graphs or is it always you usually
just have one graph and then you just
subsample it in the sense that you
create like smaller graphs of the out of
it and feed it to the internet so you're
asking about this particular um this
particular way of storing multiple
graphs or or in general is it more
common that we work on one large graph
versus many smaller graphs
uh yeah because you you want to classify
uh uh the whole network right the whole
graph you mean you yeah that was the
second problem right we're classifying
we're generating one label out of the
whole graph
yes so uh would you like do you
do you then have
multiple example graphs so you have for
example 10 example graphs and each one
has a different label and feed it to the
network or do you have like usually have
just one network available and then you
just subsample it into
smaller graphs and then try to so so in
case so in case of like problems like
with proteins or maybe
toxicity of certain substances you
usually have grafts for many substances
or many proteins or many whatever
entities you can imagine and and you
will train using many different graphs
and then you will come come up with a
new graph maybe a new protein or maybe
new drug a new drug
and you will try to predict uh the
outcome of this drug or any interaction
for this drug
in social networks you would usually
have one large graph
all or sometimes you can also subsample
this graph
you can you can cut this graph into many
graphs and so on and you can try to work
on this let's say local local structures
so usually when i'm on maybe on facebook
what is the most important are the
friends that are closer to me than those
who are you know i don't have many many
friends in common with them so
depending on the distribution you might
you might make different decisions i
don't know if this answers your question
or complicates it's even more but no
it's i guess there are different uh
use cases
yes yes yes precisely there are
different use cases
so with the different uh types of uh
graph neural networks do you have any
what is intuition when you use the
different kinds so just try the
different because in normal neural
networks i mean there's certain
neural networks that are using certain
problems right uh what is the intuition
error where should i read up maybe it's
like a huge answer so
yeah
yeah so uh
well i think it really depends so it
really depends on your problem it really
depends
um
on on the data like how feature rich it
is
how how deeply you want to look into the
graph because in some problems actually
one hop neighborhood is good enough or
two hop neighborhood right and sometimes
you have something you might have a
problem that's really simple and then it
doesn't make sense to apply a very
complex method so i can share with you
our experience from tensor cell
uh so
everything with graph neural network
started a couple of years ago um
when pavel uh pablo gora who is the
leader of this initiative he built a
graph neural network
for predicting uh
for predicting uh waiting time
in
a subset of a city
waiting time on traffic lights right and
he built a graph neural network that was
topological which means that nodes were
nodes in the neural network where
uh
where we're actually mirroring the
topology of of the crossing structure
okay and this was a pretty
uh simple architecture but it gives very
good results so i was working on the
same problem the same data said using
graph attention on one network i was not
able to beat those results right
i was able to come very very close
and and this computationally speaking
this architecture is much more complex
but i was not able to beat this result
so it really depends on your problem uh
there are also uh architectures like
graph sage that might be they might have
let's say different faces right
depending on how you
um configure them so
i don't have a definite definite answer
for you sorry
i guess maybe we have time for one last
question if
or otherwise so i don't know i think
there were at least two questions here
so i don't know
okay so maybe we can take the last one
here
yeah also thanks for the nice tutorial
thank you um
so i'm not sure judging by the formula i
saw it's basically you just insert the
features of the neighbors into the
neural network
but
do actually
yeah things our ideas exist where where
the actual structure of the network so
say you have nodes without any features
and the only feature is that they are
connected to some other nodes so for
example you want to learn like like
clustering coefficients or something
like that so really inherent network
structures so
to use this
in graph neural networks yeah so you can
have you can have uh dummy features you
can use dummy features for instance just
once
right
and then it will just uh
compute number of of nodes uh of your
neighboring notes then you can normalize
this and so on and so on so or you can
one hot encode them right so
um all those methods will allow you to
learn the graph structure without true
features in some way
those ways will be slightly different
and applicable in slightly different
problem sets let's say
but but yes
does it answer a question
partially okay
so i was wondering for example if you
want to see in a social network if
somebody is so to say an opinion leader
or so that would be judged by the number
of contacts and the way for example in
the graph continual convolutional
network you just average over the number
of nodes in the network so actually not
even the number of contacts the node has
goes not in the network it's only the
the neighbors
yes yes but but but if you feed the data
of the nodes into into your training
network
i didn't see and maybe i'm wrong in that
so i didn't see how the information of
the number of contacts for example
enters into into
your neural network the number of
contacts for example so just the number
of contacts the number of edges that go
into number of contacts how many
connections yeah
number of edges say so number of edges
so you could add a dummy feature that
says one yes but you would have to
calculate it in advance so it's not
nothing that you
feed your graph neural network with your
graph and it figures it out
automatically so that's what i mean so
it doesn't
it could so but let's take it offline
let's take it offline okay so one thing
that is clear is that this topic is very
interesting and we can go very deep but
i think it's a as a first glimpse to the
ones that we were exposed to this topic
it was a great introduction so thank you
very much thank you speaker
thank you so much